bonjour et bienvenue sur diagonale
l'actualité intercell jeu d'échecs
spécial coupe du monde avec tout de
suite en cabine pour quelques mots
laurent frayssinet bonsoir de rang
bonsoir bonsoir stéphane alors que là
nous voyons tes petites lunettes laurent
derrière l'écran d'ordinateur se loger
un petit peu voilà à l'afrique et à ses
lunettes roses et marguerites il m'a
langage châtié n'était donc voilà donc
un match c'est très intéressant entre
monsieur great choc et monsieur
gourevitch donc la jeunesse contre
l'expérience l'expérience qu'on
pronostique c'est ça qui nous intéresse
le pronostic que ces camps blitz est la
jeunesse à mon avis et sa rapidité
alexandrie ou que me semble légèrement
favori qu'en penses-tu légèrement favori
puisqu'il a des nerfs d'acier mais
gourevitch aussi donc ça va être un
match très très chaud en tout cas donc
voilà donc maintenant que vous avez vu
les commentateurs vous allez pouvoir
découvrir la salle
voilà donc à plus tard une manche eure
et loir et cher stéphane merci laurent
pour ses commentaires et bonsoir
stéphane évidemment toujours présent oui
bonsoir et loi oui donc là nous sommes
là nous attendons l'arrivée des joueurs
alors que nous voyons dans le public
hicham hamdouchi qui arrive chengdu
chine qui a été éliminé un des premiers
éliminés qui vient avec igor nataf qui
est dans le public ce soir
et quand on attaque qui est donc un ami
de alexander keith choc alors que revers
ne rejoint pas la paire fontaine nous
rejoint bonsoir bonsoir robert donc
rhabille toi et je viens souvent ses
amis voilà ne te voyons maintenant marié
vêtements voilà on te voit plus du tout
mais c'est pas grave puisque nous
attendons les joueurs cris tchouk contre
gourévitch très beau match gourevitch
c'est le champion sortant
champion du monde deux parties rapides
il a gagné la dernière coupe du monde
alors que rich schultz et la fougue de
la jeunesse la révélation de cette année
il s'en est sorti de justesse creed ou
qu'il a égalisé en remportant l'un d'eux
voilà great choc qui arrivent et
gourévitch les joueurs arrivent des
joueurs sont là donc vous rêvez d'une
bouteille à la main tombe la veste
gourévitch
alors que gretsch lui a déjà proposé nul
n'est que goran hadzic a décliné d'un
signe de tête ils ont l'air très détendu
les deux joueurs ça cache peut-être
quelque chose je ne sais pas quoi en
tout cas gourévitch s'allier il prend sa
pause habituelle
ça y est c on le voit ici courez beach
voilà alexander gris tchouk nouvelle
star de l'échiquier 19 ans 17 ans même
et oui tout à fait et gourévitch
l'expérience ancien second temps de
kasparov
il a entraîné pendant une dizaine
d'années nous allons bientôt commencer
cette partie je ne sais pas si tu as
lancé les pronostics eh bien je l'enfilé
pronostique stéphane un favori mais je
pense que gourévitch est favori mais
c'est parti c'est parti le 4 4 6 6 1 il
répète la partie d'août où tout allait
être des 5 pourrait vite chez les noirs
abeilles devraient peut-être
effectivement leurs parties semi-rapides
tout à l'heure voilà ça joue à ce niveau
là ça joue tellement vite que nous
allons regarder l'échiquier réel pour
vous commenter ces coûts puisque nous ne
pouvons pas suivre
nous approuvons pas suivre il faut donc
mettre les chiffres réels voilà pour que
nous puissions comprendre ce qu'il se
passe s'est départi de cinq minutes par
jour c'est donc extrêmement rapide et
des chats gourévitch mais la passion a
apparemment c'est quelque chose qui a
changé
il vient de jouer fous eux deux en d3 un
sacrifice de pion à cette liste
d'options c'est un retardement comme un
retardé mental et il se sacrifie
d'options le faire je m'en foutais 3
tout tout de suite
il le joue et gourévitch relève le défi
il prend en d4
puis on prend des 4 et cavalli prend des
katibas berry gourévitch c'est parti
cavalli prend ils ont leurs habitués de
de faire des bruits de 5 puisqu'il
débute vraiment tous les coups à namur
certaines sacrifice d'un deuxième pion
en séquençant deuxième pion est
difficile à prendre
non on peut le prendre quand même mais
c'est un peu pénible je pense pas que
vous ravit tu vas prendre ses pions là
plutôt ramener la dame sur la case b6
c'est ce qu'ont fait normalement et
voilà il a fait bois beach il connaît
très très bien
la défense française
c'est parti dame jusqu'à 4 1 vas-y
thématiques dans cette position ces
thématiques de jouer ce genre de coup ça
a l'air complètement fausses alarmes des
bastions ça empêche le faut être fier de
sortir faut s'accrocher encore un pion
l'option b dom et je ne pense pas que
gouaille tu vas prendre ce pion damas
cinq dames à 5 c il ya un net avantage
pour gourévitch non robert dans cette
position oui c'est possible mais
attention une riche ou que c'est
tellement g4 qui fixe le fouet fuite
alors peut-être que mon avis tu vas
jouer qu'avec j'ai six communes
australia h4 qui est toujours embêtant
h4 effectivement c'est jusqu'à 300 c'est
l'idée de ce sacrifice de pions de toute
manière on peut pas parler véritablement
davantage puisque en anglais donc même
une position supérieure n'indique pas
forcément le résultat
en revanche on peut parler de bilan
pendule il reste trois minutes 50 aux
deux joueurs
donc c'est tout à fait équilibré crête
chopra que 17 ans gourévitch à 40 ans
d'expérience déjà dans les échecs c'est
vraiment à d'alger 3 un petit coup un
petit coup qui ne menace rien protège le
pion aux cinq sur un éventuellement un
coup de cavaliers de gourévitch on voit
vite shire joue kbc 6 quand même on va
le voir sur l'écran voilà donc aller
bien sûr la casse et 6 pour attaquer le
pion aux cinq cavaliers b5 serait
un coup c'est un terrain stable tout à
fait robert puisque pour la vie tchô
menace des cinq des quatre à l'avant
séduction centrale qui ferait une fort
qu fourchette donc une fourchette sur le
fouet le cavalier qu'elle et b5
effectivement est envisageable
même s'il peut noter qu'on peut aussi
envisager ensuite des coups comme f4 et
f5
c'est vrai mais je pense que vous aurez
vite fait pas de toute façon jouer g6
très prochainement donc ça ne marchera
pas mais là on s'inquiète comme pour que
tous qui réfléchit beaucoup beaucoup il
n'y a plus que trois minutes il a
presque 40 secondes de retard
hélas comme c'est vraiment du sport un
bien de ça commence à être beaucoup quel
dessein qu'il a fait il est parti sur la
case des cinq sacrifier encore un pion
puisque qu'on va vite je peux prendre le
pion aux 5 peut prendre le pion aux 5
ça al'air aisée mais défendue par l'adam
robert oui mais fou le fond de cette
attaque avec son attaque labellisés bac
et je crois qu'il l'a fait peut-être
gourévitch qu'il a fait il l'a fait
wayne qu'est-ce qui se passe
quelle est la pointe les skinheads c'est
que les noirs ont du mal à développer
maintenant torah c'est un tout
simplement tour à sa suite pour cette
grosse grosse pression là énorme
pression énorme pression sur gourévitch
comment va-t-il sortir ces pièces
fawcett je pense mais fawcett donnerait
purger saint-eloi d'amd cmb scène assez
bien vu sur tours c'est cette il ya food
et 6 simplifiant dans la finale final
nettement avantageuse pour gourévitch on
met à table des six il a fait comme ses
trois peut-être fou et 7 dans cette
position et non il ne peut pas qu'est-ce
qu'il peut jouer qu'on va vite ch
mais food & cie sa valeur ils y
attacheront j'ai cette fosse est quand
même nous dérange expression que les
chocs là où la cohabittion blier quelque
chose on a vite oublié quelque chose
mais il a tout simplement oublié qu'il
pouvait prendre je sais qu'à mon avis il
aurait fui dit le coup il est perdant
gourévitch tous réfutent tours fc 1-1 et
oui oui il s avère très très difficile
maintenant ça y est c'est fini qu'on a
vu de chez complètement perdant
pulvérisé par getxo car elle peut
prendre la tour mais donc puisque à ce
moment là oui mais s'il prend la tour il
ya d'armes 30 aux échecs
au fond les foules couvre une fois je
sais ce qu'il va faire il était obligé
de faire ça il faut effet voilà c'est
fait bilan pendule 2 minutes 30 à chaque
joueur très chaud pour ses 1 sur 5 ou
fléchissent au choix pour ces 1 d'abord
en prendre un cône la tour cn s'est
terminée il ya poussé 5 qui arrive et il
a une pièce de claude choquet d'albi 6
pouces et 5 5 un bon tour ses huit tours
sémites la ressource de gourévitch avec
le mag du couloir
surtout ces cinq il ya tour s'est vite
oui mais c'est grave
la menace de boer à vis de ces rois 17
et il peut encore jouer au ballon chaud
conséquent été perdants pour apprendre
le pion à celle de toute manière et oui
faire très très chaud très chaud
alors est-ce que le geste technique et
un lieu voilages 3 voilà la chaleur h4
roi des singes un rendement à l'essai
d'un proche cette voie là attaqué le bus
il faut le défendre pas si facile il
faut jouer à wii se redonne sept il y à
fuji 5éme cetto que tout a une longueur
d'avancé sur gourévitch il voit plus
vite que gourevitch et oui c'est avec un
financement alors l'art était aussi très
difficile pour vince câble installé à
damas il va le pousser à 5h 6h 7h huit
dames
voilà deux minutes chacun maintenant
va s'accélérer 3,8 défend depuis 27 oui
peut-être le seul coup h5 maintenant on
voit mal comment on pourrait vite je
peux arrêter le plus proche ça joue
sajoo h5 a l'air de faire très mal
daoudji vite peut-être non
date limite effective j'évite savvis
savitz il est physique sachant qu encore
une fois ce passif sur fond c'est ça
qu'on est sur ces 5 et bien je crois que
m g7
ralala à gourévitch il se bat comme un
lion comme un lion dame g7 s'est bien vu
c'est très bien vu de la part de gorée
biais sur x 600 fois ci s'il faut
revenir en d6 avec la dame mais il a
trouvé une belle défense la mort est
vite allé fois çi c'est fort quand même
a les cheveux foncés s'inquiète m g7
n'ont h5 belge ça donc je sais ça me
prend feu prend ça va très vite c'est
pas si clair cette position est quand
même coach look a l'air mieux pour ces
deux un petit coup en 3d cette hôtesse
des 4 et des 323 17 est vraiment bon 17
et tours s'est vite
ouais il ya égalité matérielle des cats
est plus fort je pense retournement de
situation il semblerait que culture qui
fait une faute il n'aurait pas dû
permettre l'échangé les dames c'est
clair je suis moi je suis normalement
faut bien je suis toi là le tueur ne
passera plus secura beach il a repris du
poil de la bête ça se voit ça se voit à
sa tête il est en train de générer des
idées à 0 à saint quentin sur une menace
le oui de chercher le pion h mais ça va
pas être évident je trouvais ça brise en
hausse des droits maintenant tombé
drague des trois concepts nature temps
tout à fait chic et a beaucoup de retard
joué 4 à la caisse qu'il peut faire pour
éviter tout rage 5 maintenant allez on
voit le temps qu'ils se déplacent
lentement pour attaquer le pion
et ce qu'ils font pas tout il va faire
flux des deux de la donne augurant ainsi
ce que je sais que ça doit donner
dimanche le touquet oui mais craque un
peu là ces cinq sur six mois dans un
cheminement mais sa pendule il reste une
vision tisser gourévitch et 50 secondes
a great choc on a oublié la radio ça va
se jouer sans sa voiture aux nerfs
surtout toi à six fours b4 olalalala
c'est c'est surprenant
m6 ils remplaceront fugure beach c'est
très très chaud un point de retournement
de situation et énormément de
retournement de situation nous proposer
l'échangé tour en refusant externe dès 6
ans fermement de la tour de grède choc
première progresser avec les normes des
retours de cris de choc et ont fermé
mais pas pour longtemps
ainsi peut-être et oui de 5 f ça c'est
une faute roi henri iv un énorme faute
de droit maintenant ils se décomposent
il se décompose dans cette partie voilà
il va les entendre exactement comment
gagner il reste 35 secondes à chacun ses
tonnerre mais courait vite chez gagnant
et il sait comment faire
échanges oh là là ça y est c'est fini ça
c'est le coup de massue on aurait celui
de vienne avec vous et allez ça va jouer
autant maintenant objet d'échangé tour
c'est une finale de pions et là il n'y a
plus aucun espoir pour bioshock aucun
d'espoir
et la réflexion il regarda est synonyme
d'abandon oui là c'est terminé
et oui abandon de gris tchouk abandon de
greccio gourévitch à gagner cette partie
à noter que les joueurs ne se sont pas
serré la main oui bizarre c'est très
curieux
c'est très curieux vraiment surprenant
tout ça courez vite ch gagne donc la
première partie avec les noirs après des
retournements de situations complètement
incroyable complètement incroyable
robert la vérité il était perdant il
était perdant il a réussi à voir que
deux ou trois minutes de repos avant de
faire la seconde partie huawei n'a été
perdant il a retourné la situation et
belle technique en finale loi eh ben
c'est à dire que choquer un peu sabordé
sa position il était gagnant il s'est
laissé entraîner sur la finale et
ensuite pour éviter a été complètement
impitoyable il ya pris le pion à 6 sur
faute de night shop et après c'était du
déroulage il a simplement déroulée les
coûts qu'aurait beach très très
facilement facilement et gourévitch à
l'eiblen encore à noter que dans dans
les parties 50 une demi heure chacun
gourévitch a perdu avec les blancs aussi
gravité a perdu que les blancs c'est
vrai que dans les blitz les plans sais
pas si important que ça robert et
pascale plus important ce qui est
important c'est les nerfs et c'est jouer
vite et gré de choc on sait qu'il en a
pour rich a déjà montré tout à l'heure
qu'il avait qu'il n'avait pas réussi à
fuir nulle avec les blancs maintenant
effectivement c'est très complexe comme
situation
donc là alors que nous voyons sur scène
larbitre qui remet les pièces voilà il
est en train de ranger tout à fait
larbitre toujours de dos
oui ils ont pourtant fait remarquer
qu'il valait mieux se mettre face à la
caméra mais il ne peut pas le faire
alors qu'on vend et loue à seraing avec
des lunettes avec de belles lunettes
oui tout à fait puisque ici nous sommes
à cannes sur la côte d'azur donc il faut
s'adapter au milieu ça fait un peu hein
alors que c'est toi tu es du sud ouest
mais tu n'es pas adapté à la vente qu'à
trois noms tu peux nous montrer que tu
n'as pas de lunettes fictivement alors
que notre réalisateur demande des choses
curieuses je l' ai donc dans mon
oreillette oreillettes qui n'est pas
vraiment une oreillette mais plutôt un
casque intégral mais bon c'est la
technologie cannoise
voilà donc voilà donc ce qui est en
train de se passer
et là nous avons à l'image trois
commentateurs pour deux joueurs ce qui
est ce qui veut donc dire que c'est un
peu curieux
oui
j'entends des bruits curieux dans mon
oreille
je crois que je vais enlever le casque
six fils et s'est complètement ingérable
ça va beaucoup mieux tout de suite là je
n'ai plus les commentaires comportant
des voiliers qui sortent de l'appareil
mais bon il est en train de s'étouffer
le pauvre homme tout seul rien à voir
avec les échecs
ouais il faut donc recentrer le débat
alors stéphane un pronostic pour le
deuxième mais je pense que pour éviter
bien placé et qu' il devrait arriver à
faire en moins nul avec les blancs
d'autant plus qu'il a l'expérience
d'avoir perdu la revanche de tout à
l'heure donc il va pas se laisser avoir
deux fois robert un petit pronostic
oui oui je pense que glee show va gagner
là je le sens bien avec les normes alors
c'est pas du tout le même profil que
vous avez un an je pense que j'ai tout
cas les nerfs et il va revenir parce que
c'était pas clair il a quand même on
voit qu'ils jouent très bien au blitz et
je pense qu' ils pourront plus revenir
dans le match
oui tout à fait mais là en tout cas il
n'avait pas les nerfs dans cette partie
justement il n'avait pas les nerfs mais
on sait jamais c'est un russe peut-être
un griot qui s'est laissé intoxiquer par
secor matin s est pas facile c'est pas
facile de se concentrer étoile et moi
mon pronostic est bien c'est que
dans un premier temps je vais réfléchir
mais ici je vais vous parler maintenant
je pense que pourrait vite je ne va pas
perdre cette partie mais nulle ou gain
de goualich ça n'a aucune importance
puisque de toute façon gourevitch
seraient qualifiés ouais donc
effectivement je pense que quelque chose
ne gagnera pas c'est la seule chose qui
est importante à dire dans la cabine
d'un côté nous avons laurent frayssinet
jean-luc chavanon warrants fascine et
qui a des lunettes jaunes et oui c'est
la mode des lunettes rassemblant à
cannes même s'il n'ya pas de soleil
j'ai pas besoin de soleil pour porter
des lunettes donc là nos joueurs sont un
peu longs en jeu troupes qu'est ce
qu'ils font mais c'est moi je trouve que
c'est bizarre qui ne se sont pas serré
la main on les a vu discuter
tranquillement comme des amis avant la
partie et tout d'un coup on sape à la
main c'est vraiment étrange
c'est bizarre à une preuve de grand fair
play alors qu'aulas notre réalisateur
s'amuse à faire un plan en incrustation
de la table de jeu est mis à mal
il est fort ce réalisateur ouais je vais
écouter ce qu'il a à nous dire
d'ailleurs à titre exceptionnel alors
françois un petit mot un petit mot
peut-être
non pas de gros mots autre chose on fait
encore pas ça là un effet non non je ne
dirai rien voilà un accueil sans faille
et c'est la cagade du réalisateur c'est
des écrits de plusieurs bus trash on a
droit à des effets terribles moi c'est
vachement sympa tout ça mais ça ne fait
pas avancer le débat
oui c'est bizarre que assaillent et les
chics et s'est remis en place
normalement aussi bien au niveau visuel
et me voilà bien me voilà tout aplati
telle une crêpe est oui a décidément
elle s'amuse bien non françois tu peux
arrêter là voilà merci françois on te
remercie de toute façon c'est difficile
de commenter une stéphane je crois que
je crois qu'il faut bien dire bon là on
nous commentons grand échiquier vide
alors effectivement c'est vrai que
naples qui a commenté les amusements
d'initiateur alors que la position est
de nouveaux talents qu'est ce qui se
passe aussi pour éviter tu perds la
partie et bien il y aura un partout
stéphane oui mais dis donc qu'est ce qui
se passe là encore de blitz où il y en a
plus qu'un il faudra départager les
joueurs c'est sûr et donc une formule
n'a été trouvée par par l'organisation
ici ils vont faire un pile ou face suivi
d'une mare elle puisque
ils n'ont pas trouvé d'autres systèmes
ils n'ont pas pensé à faire une deuxième
chez les british des marelles il faut
aller jusqu'au ciel c'est ça c'est ça
mais je pense qu'on va leur souffler
l'idée de faire une nouvelle série de
liszt ça sera peut-être adopté alors que
nous sommes sur les caméras tonique et
que se passe-t-il pourquoi pourquoi les
gens ne mais il ya peut-être justement
quelque chose de curieux qui est en
train de se passer
qui est en train de se passer peut-être
que les joueurs n'ont pas envie de jouer
et la main l'avons judit polgar dans le
public avec son mari on nous signale à
la régie j'espère que c'est son mari
c'est malin c'est vrai c'est assez malin
à j'ai dit que le gars sur l'écran géant
elle va se voir puisqu'elle est diffusé
sur l'écran géant de cannes est là quand
elle s'est vue elle encore et voilà bon
les joueurs arrivent alors fini de jouer
nous allons reprendre gourévitch écrits
de chou qui se serrent la main
gourévitch à l'eiblen il faut qu'il
fasse nul ou gagner pour se qualifier et
jouer demain contre eux contre biarritz
kasparov
garry kasparov inglee personnes le king
de bakou peut-être justement que ces
partis des arbitres à la route rail
alors nous passons tout de suite sur
l'échiquier la position et voilà superbe
ces quatre pour les coûts de goa beach
une anglaise
l'estonie l'espagne heim une espagnole
qu'est ce que c'est que ce coup de
brebis de fouché simple et l'estonien
avec fous j'ai cinq petit rock e3 une
variante donc solide mais là il ya un
service de pions connu qui est
intéressant pour les noirs je crois
qu'on joue ses 7 et 5 puis on prend des
quatre des cinq après pour transférer
dans une sorte de grünfeld améliorée
bessy sketch où peugeot un système
rampant je sais pas si ça va réussir à
décontenancer gourévitch il en a joué
des positions et ça y est tout de suite
ils veulent changer les pièces
il est horrible gourévitch camani s'est
si souvent c'est vraiment qu'éviter
échange une ouverture très bizarre ça
est loin nous avons du mal à y croire
savons beaucoup de mal à y croire corey
reach est vraiment très très solide
youtube a mis ses deux fous en pierre
catteau oui surtout le cavalier ans et
si c'est un peu bizarrement habitude on
joue des six cavalli b17 voyez on est
normalement on ne veille pas les pièces
devant les pions ouais c est bizarre et
or y réfléchir et juke
il se dit d'ailleurs la pression n'est
pas bonne des six
ouh là là le pauvre le tchouk h3 il
avec gambeat je n'y fait rien il est
parti pour une longue souffrance chocun
bas c'est à dire que gourevitch wifi il
n'y a pas besoin de faire grand chose
il est un petit peu mieux et juri
tranquillement rapidement avec
l'expérience qu'il a alors ça c'est une
formation dite de l'hippopotame avec
cette structure de pions oui
maximum de pièces et gourévitch
gourévitch il a l'expérience qu'il faut
il joue cavalier eux quatre ils
échangent toutes les pièces il n'y aura
plus de pièces très chic et son objectif
net est de faire nul ne veut pas faire
autre chose que nul ça suffit
l'expérience parle l'expérience de
réagir et vite ch commence à réfléchir
c'est pas bon signe il a déjà une minute
de retard 4 minutes 30 pour moi beach 3
minutes 30 pour grichka c'est dur c'est
décourageant tout ça il ne sait pas quoi
faire
riccio qu il faut qu'ils soient des
clous peut-être le coup h6 norvège
sisters un avion cavaliers à 5 car il ya
5 qui permet les échanges de toutes les
pièces sauf deux cavaliers alors je
pense que bourg abidjan il apparaît déjà
deux fois qu'on peut ajouter des pièces
ça y est là on sait que moi y'a deux
pièces moyen de chances de gain est donc
gourévitch a évidemment il saute sur
tous les échanges sachant que dieu lui
assure une qualification en demi finale
de cette coupe du monde à cannes et donc
le titre de champion du monde se
rapprochent pouvant bien rallye
gourévitch tour des huit
il sait pas trop quoi faire choqué et c3
vauvy chat ou jouer tempo il a plus
d'une minute d'avancé maintenant
gourévitch je crois qu'il va encore se
rendre en deçà des 5 quoi il enfermé le
cavalier 17° choke maintenant aux cinq
matches ferme la position à noter que la
position est évidemment équilibré ya pas
davantage pour qui que ce soit comme des
deux dames 7
1 4 qui intrigue ferme tout il faire le
tout alors que nous avons en
incrustation en plan avec les pièces de
l'échiquier
tout ça ne fait pas ne va pas sauver
great choc contre le joueur belge
mérigots à bitche
ouais on voit mal comment il pourrait
s'en sortir main
la rapidité est induite il veut jouer f5
qui peut jouer avec f5 effectivement il
veut replacer son cavalier aussi qu'on
va vite se prépare psychologiquement à
l'avancé f 100 cavaliers v7 est très mal
placé de ce cavalier stéphane c'est
qu'on ne sait jamais trop où leurs
maîtres g iii wima améliorer
tranquillement la position de son roi je
crois qu'il veut jouer avec 4 surtout
nous rawicz avec le cavalier des huit
c'est normal là il a eu droit jeudi
et puis f4 pour défendre le curage trois
voies de droit j'ai deux f-16 jeu vite
f-16 pour replacer le cavalier d'abord
f4 gars il va jouer cinq simone hcfc
impression qui a été obligé de prendre
de jouer cavalier de 7 après il est
maintenant c'est g5 dans cette position
orageux et oui et gorica pas je
traiterai on n'est pas si malgré tout il
est pas si mal ça y est il est en train
de revenir complètement et du g5 voilà
je crois qu'il a bien géré cette
position et 5 7 5
ça y est rich ou qui est légèrement
mieux et juke est légèrement mieux
gourévitch incroyable or équipe craquer
et oui c'est possible comme des trois
pions prend 1,4 savvis cavalli prend
ensuite qu'avaya sheets huit cavaliers 5
et loi ça va hein t'as fait cavaler
prend 1,4 à échouer nantes au point un
capteur et je continue à changer les
rails agi de manière ils continuent à
échanger toutes les pièces mairie
gourevitch il a trouvé un plan je change
tout et je reviendrai deux minutes pour
grichka trois minutes pour gourévitch
c'est oui il joue au petit avantage
prendre ajoute non effectivement
effectivement il ya probablement un
petit avantage à greccio la pièce de
court et vite choix quand même très
élyséen qu'il va mettre son cavalière f5
et ensuite sur la case des quatre de
tous donc j'ai eu un hiver très bien
acheter une recharge joué avec beaucoup
d'énergie
on a vu gourévitch d'arriver sur la
pendule
alors que l'arbitré fait signe à
l'arbitré des gants signaleurs mitre
s'énerve un but de dos évidemment
évidemment il est toujours de dos
cavaillé f5 joué par alexander gretsch
hook et oui il même si on réussit ce
gage de touristes pourrait vite
non mais je pense que tout récit serait
pas mal trop si c'est le bon coup pour
aux 6 à noter qu'il ya quelques décades
pour chasser la tour c'est très chaud il
a trouvé des chances riccio kessy
contrefiche le rattrape autant eh bien
ça va être horriblement chaud tout
reprend togo nous invite il s'en tient à
ça m'a aidé à me cas peut-être après
tout à fait il va tout prendre et
changent et changent des dames tout a
été changé
petit bug les deux tours oulalala énorme
bug de l'ordinateur qui ne va plus
retrouver la position de d'amendé sept
et plus tour en 1 voilà exactement vous
enlevez les pièces lourdes et vous avez
la position qu'il joue en ce moment même
une énorme bug de l'ordinateur tout à
fait tout à fait un bug
gigantesque maigri choqué mieux riccio
qui est légèrement mieux mais il peut
pas passer avec son roi de tchouk on
voit qu'il est bloqué par le pion
dessins quelques caves et des rues car
il faut protéger les pions de n'dam eloi
je sais pas si c'est si simple
oui s'il met le cavalier en c3 tout
simplement et oui mais lequel ces trois
vallées c'est assez loin noir et ça il
n'en a pas envie
voilà qui est c3 maintenant de youtube
implorant f6 et qui a valu aux quatre
chèques de quatre échecs à un endroit
qu'ils avaient obligé avant de partir et
oui oui donc il rejoue son cas médicaux
tchouk alors que la l'échiquier notre
wable complètement planté ça a
complètement quand ya pas la seule en
venu nous y sommes la position est
revenue c'est la position correcte
vous rêvez je ne crains pas grand chose
ici un nom il ne craint pas la jouer f5
qui va échanger les pions il prouve
qu'il est capable de faire de l'humour
rigoureux beach alors qu'on ne sait plus
à qui c'est de jouer
mais mitch manteau blanc une minute 5
pour grid ans c'était au noir il a joué
à six et la pendule breton avec continue
à tourner il reste une minute dix saga
turin ya trois semaines je suis la
preuve de goût riche quand même si il
l'a préparé quelque chose de tout votre
alliée à la doc va jouer à fond
cavalier à 4 comme il ya quatre il y
aurait b5 et peut-être pas sourd du
cavalier en c3 je ne sais pas je ne sais
pas ce qui peut se passer dans cette
position mais a priori gourevitch
devrait tirer sa bulle rien n'est fait
un une minute pour chaque joueur
maintenant
oulala ça va se jouer à la rapidité se
joue également au der une minute chacun
restantes gourévitch à semble-t-il
trouvé un plan il va forcer le trait il
joue très très vite bouricha sait il a
passé la surmultipliée mihailovic cgri
chucky le premier pers
c'est normal c'est lui de gagner il peut
prendre les jouer à quatre ça lui fera
que passer
oui mais à ce moment là et oui le
courant du mois ses protégés seraient
favoris mais il faut peut-être qu'il
peut jouer avec bekka payack joue avec
b4 et oui choque un peu mieux là où dans
le piège est ce un cahier de vie
toujours une solution
c'est terrible c'est terrible ça va très
bien ça joue très très vite
oui alors qu'on me demande est ce que l
arbitre est au courant qu'il a un public
qui avait 10 ans h 5 secondes il a pris
le plus d'accidents et de cinq richaud
qui est gagnant ça y est ça y est il est
gagnant greggio il a pris +1 2 point
brian myles et va égaliser fantastique
fantastic gris tchouk va égaliser dans
cette partie il reste 35 secondes
normaliser la réunion et chose
incroyable ce qui se passe dans ce match
quel suspense insoutenable richie va
jouer il a brandi la bande à houilles et
la banda de fabuleux égalisation à
gagner cette partie et égalisation
incroyable de crise
ou qui décidément 10e joueur qui gagne
avec les noirs à chaque fois il est
vraiment extraordinaire ce gris tchouk
et madrid ça je viendrai visible à la
vie alors qu'est ce qui va se passer ce
qu'il faut encore d'obliques sous un
seul et bien pour ça il faut aller se
renseigner
je suis folle et se rend chez va les
voir voilà c'est pour ça ainsi stéphane
en correspondance spéciale auprès des
autorités compétentes alors que robert
nous allons continuer à chercher de le
continuer à parler un petit peu grosse
partie et normes techniques du griffoul
dans la finale cédant à ses fabuleuses
qui s'est passé c'est incroyable
d'arriver à battre gourévitch dans cette
position alors que courait vite on le
sait est quand même un technicien
redoutable
remarquez rien voulu changer toutes les
pièces et finalement il s'est pris dans
son propre piège puisque grisou a été
meilleur que lui dans la finale de
cavaliers c'est rare effectivement
d'autant plus que la finale était sans
doute nul tout à fait tout à fait nul
donc impressionnant great choque
vraiment impressionnant là nous voyons
l'écran géant qui a diffusé la can et
bien à greccio gourévitch premiers
matches 1 point pour bourrer vite chez
deuxième match à point pour red book
comme souvent dans ce match eh bien ça
en devienne la première est il permis
second alors qu on me souffle des
phrases âmes curieuses les phrases
curieuse alors que nous voyons sur scène
c'est un à la borne c'était faire
n'importe qui est là qui demande
stephen green ce qui se passe et stephen
boyd
apparemment tu n'es pas au courant
heureusement il va lui dire quelque
chose
stéphane détendu alors que stéphane
revient il va revenir stéphane qu'est ce
qu'il va nous dire ouh là là mais où il
va je crois qu'il s'est trompé d'endroit
non c'est bon voilà est tout à fait tout
à fait stéphane revient on le voit
dans l'allée et pas mal de monde pour il
est 22 heures il est assez tard oui il
ya plus d'une centaine de personnes dans
la salle
c'est quand même pas mal alors que nous
voyons
stephen boyd qui remet les pièces sur
scène le voilà fanboy qui est donc
larbitre de ce tournoi alors que
stéphane va revenir et nous dire ce qui
est prévu alors que dans la cabine
dakota est également fasciné qui fait
des signes sais pas je ne sais pas ce
qu'ils veulent nous dire que veut-il
dire laurent fasciné alors stéphane que
se passe-t-il
voilà j'ai l'information donc il s'agit
de deux blitz est encore de blitz il ya
encore égalité au bout des deux buts il
y aura la mort subite allait bien mort
subite c'est chaud ça c'est les femmes
bah oui c'est le premier qui perd qui
aura perdu ou le premier qui gagne qui
aura gagné
voilà alors que laurent frayssinet nour
joint aux cabines oui voilà en effet
donc je ne sais pas ce que les
commentaires que vous avez donnée mais
moi j'ai été stupéfait par la technique
d'ike turner est choquée en moins de 30
secondes
attention il y avait une minute 0,4 à la
fin il y aurait 33 secondes et donc la
position égal en moins de 30 secondes
il a pris trois pions et des cavaliers à
amical go à 8 qui avait une mine de plus
alors moi j'ai trouvé ça complètement
énorme jeu la vue je les ai déjà vus
jouer sur le sur internet en bits et il
m'avait déjà impressionné mais alors là
je suis vraiment je suis presque
amoureuse d'alexandre junca riccio que
vraiment son style a beaucoup plu je
sais pas ce que tu en penses
alors comme laurent frayssinet donc
moqueries dans l'oreille au lieu de
parler au micro les soirs c'est pas ma
ses rangs ce n'est pas grave il y avait
tout à fait il a bu je crois qu'il a vu
laurent frayssinet mais ce n'est pas
grave ce qui est important c'est son
entrain et des jeunes rappelons qu'il a
l'âge de gris tchouk plus deux ans
puisqu'il a 19 ans laurent frayssinet
que c'est quelque chose quand on a
dix-sept donc laurent tués
dans la même catégorie à peu près que je
veux aucun voilà donc je vais vu au
cours de beaucoup de compétitions jeunes
et c'est vrai qu'ils sont à lens s'est
révélée un peu sur le tard les banques
c'était quand même ses carnets du lycée
comme les petits russa et ils apprennent
d'abord les finales et ensuite et une
passe aux ouvertures pour venir
massacrés et je vouvoyais gretsch ou
proviennent à d'accord dans les shows
provient donc merci le rond pour ses
commentaires
et voilà ça y est c'est reparti klitscho
gourévitch deuxième série de blitz pour
huit chalets blanc encore une fois donc
évidemment pourrais tu vas gagner c'est
prévu commentant le règlement corps et
les ducs avec les blancs et pair avec
les non non c'est l'inversé l'averse
greffe je peux gagner maintenant ah oui
c'est ça change la sécurité de calais
blanc promis d c'est pas de chance a été
interné c'est pas de chance il va être
mené tout de suite puisque dans ce match
quelque chose gourevitch c'est toujours
les noirs qui gagne larbitre va mettre
en marche sa pendule incroyable il est
face au public leurs vitres et oui oui
c'est parti ça y est alors position et
voilà c'est cap c'est reparti pour une
anglaise mais non 12 h ou de change
c'est une défense news au beach où là ça
va très très bien c'est ça va sur le
seul islam a c'est une soliste avec dom
français cap
on se rappelle de la partie kasparov
gramlich la dernière partie du match qui
donna le titre de champion du monde abel
devient chronique c'était à peu près
pareil
et là on vous donne le mandat de ces
deux fous j'ai cinq sets au choix qui
sera choisi
5 maigrichon connais très bien cette
partie car je connais très bien avec moi
beach aussi c'est ça qui est bien c'est
que tout le monde connaît bien les cinq
dames c'est de fouler 7 3 un petit coup
le petit coup à noter que c'est le
troisième blitz et donc les joueurs sont
moins
- comment dire moins précis puisque
maison en plus il se laisse entraîner
par la rapidité des actions et donc la
pétition à dominante verte
oui exactement maintenant c'est vraiment
les nerfs c'est tout simplement les
nerfs qui joue est-ce que vous rêvez g20
trouvé les ressources suffisantes
il a mené deux fois au score dans ce
match il s'est fait rejoindre deux fois
c'est pas facile à 6 la grille de choc
qui prépare le pouce et 5 ou à vide qui
l'empêchent changement à 2 à 4 il faut
empêcher cette poussée libératrice en c5
est ce qu il a fait une chute il a joué
le fou sur les tests des théâtres avec
un chèque au roi avec un petit échec
cavaliers bd2 petit rock normalement on
doit suivre peinture entre deux côtés
d'ailleurs le tyran qui est petit rock
tout à fait de petits rôles devraient
arriver c'est important de mettre
l'europe à l'abri
c'est clair
voilà qu'est ce qui se passe c'est
gritche ou encore je suis en retard au
temps en retard annoncé qu il a cinq
secondes de retard et c'est en train de
s'accroître
là c'est le moment du plan est chaude
davie doit choisir le plan peut être
petit rock peut-être c5
il a fait ces cinq sacrifice d'options
pour éviter avec moi maman avec npo mais
je ne crois pas qu'il n'a qu il a pris
des saints il ya d'abord si three
lecavalier f6 très curieux mais
l'arbitré curieux pas peur d'eux
gourevitch qu'est ce qu'il a vu j'ai
tout fait d'après réussissent à perm en
cours et vit déjà vu quelque chose je
prends grave et les prières du cavalier
que se passe-t-il si elle admet il mais
sans l'option b 5 fu prend pions vous
procurer des soins f3 puis on prend
peut-être surprendre car jean marie adam
smith et jeanne et gemplus pour wisches
mais non mais qu'on va vite chez
beaucoup mieux il est beaucoup mieux
gourévitch et pourquoi l'on est bien
parce qu'après petit rock je fais pions
prend ses 5
et oui oui mais
un bon piont plus écoeurant qui sera
très bien sur les cases eux deux ça va
être très solides tout ça petit renvoie
là c'est le bon coup claude choules a
joué et maintenant la revente voirie
cheval prend dans ses 5
ça ferait un peu plus mais le roi blanc
pendant total sécurisé quand quatre
petits rôles 3 h 1 ça y est j'ai appris
en c5
il a lancé cinq pions prend b5
les tours sont en vis-à-vis maintenant
il faut choisir entre tourcoing tours ou
à deux tout de suite je pense qu'il va
d'abord prendre à temps et ensuite sur
deux voilà c'est le flex tampon dame
prend ses 3 2 laissant passer la
deuxième tour à noter la lenteur du
déplacement des pièces sur l'échiquier
vous voyez voilà ça y est c'est bon
c'est mis à jour inclut en plus pour
mitrailler gourévitch et surtout ses 8
qu'est ce qui s'passe robert évident de
gamme animé trois quarts il est roi
voilà on tient le pion tient le pion à
jouer la tour en 1 1 et le plan b 5 est
encore faible
un pronostic l'a rapidement sur cette
position mais les blancs sont mieux les
chemins anglais choc va gagner quelque
chose gagner stéphane mais je pense que
gourévitch vallini moi et toi et moi et
moi je pense pas grand chose avait après
ce coup après ce coup de massue j'ai un
petit avantage sur vous je suis
quasiment sûr que mon avis tu vas gagner
cette partie où là il a fait un signe de
la tête gourévitch qui darde peut-être
raté quelque chose qui à mon avis n'est
pas
n'est pas tranquille l'inde qu'avec des
cas peut-être dans cette position voilà
des pièces de gourévitch monte
adroitement et le fou degré de choquant
b4 vous le voyez est très mal placé net
avantage mérigots allégé faut se lâcher
l'accent de f5 f5 oui mais il y à foot
est roi simplement robert et windham
décisive à jouer pour ces lingots à
bitche voix non non non qu'est ce qu'il
a fait je sais pas afp archives quatre
f4 il prend les devants cavaliers g4 et
g4 peut-être un coup comme fou et 3
serait le bienvenu dans cette position
je verrais bien qu'on va vite chaque
fois 2009 d'accor du coup le site ce 5e
tour g1 tout simplement a touché 1 c'est
très intéressant système des trois de
mener trois ans et mystérieux ils vont
attaquer le pion bessin qui attaquent le
pion aux mécènes qui menace de prendre
les 5 c'est à dire tu ne peux pas le
défendre ou c5 élevé ses cinq
permettrait faux en écriture dans le
premier cinq mille ans et joue
exactement quel choc veut garder les
dames dans cette position et il a raison
c'est comme ça qu'il va réussir à s'en
sortir mais là je pense que oui jo
torcéen un autre coup cavaliers plutôt
fraîche 3 et là il ya le 5 normalement
sur cinq il faut projet cat et le foot
j'ai attaqué la tour s'est vite tout à
fait robert tour d un normalement
pour ces 1 peut-être tour c'est un tour
c'est un mais pas davantage à gourévitch
énorme avantage pour pourrait vite à
illzach alors pendule
il reste trois minutes à courir vite
chez deux autres atouts qu donc pour à
bitche et bien autant mieux à la
position
à noter que pour evi çetin mangeurs de
pions on ne donne pas impunément
d'options à gourévitch il le prend dame
c4 a été joué il va jouer il veut jouer
ces sept
quant à bitche c'est tendu tous a déjoué
d'un profond surtout il a pris les rênes
cahier des caps dans le monde a envie
d'entreprendre de la dame
évidemment pour échanger des pièces
changées la dame est là on va tout cas
le choix entre dame prend d'amour autre
chose et gretsch au tannat 5 1 co
responsable qui parlait c'est cette non
il en a l'impression que c'est cette
date tout de suite c'est cette c'est
très fort savannah sous bessette
non c'est cette histoire princesse et à
tous ses membres il ya une dynamique
échec
ces sept avaient l'air de le gagner et
c'est cette a encore l'air de gagner oui
mais camélidés 5 pts est très loin oui
c'est vrai la sq a validé cinq mois les
ateliers d'art et tout de suite
est ce qu'il va faire gourévitch chance
qui m'est celle d'améliorer sa position
du tabac c'est ça ramassez le pion mai
et la finale sera tranquille tout à fait
robert il peut échanger les dames
gourévitch en cette pression s'ils y
arrivent et oui mais il arrive échanges
et david sera complètement jugeant père
l'option b impossible de le défendre
impossible de le défendre dans beesan
qui est l'un des cinq tours mais 4 à 1
en panne on intègre les chiens c'est
beaucoup d'abeilles 4 sans doute de goa
beach juana story 4 un choix curieux et
d5 le chase comprendre et ça qu'il faut
compter cinq ans en fumée mais le wild à
une couple fort que le cavalier doit
c'est vraiment prendre les 5 maintenant
d'un machin
menaces et ses 7 s'est jamais un sacré
choc a vu des trucs là il crée tout cas
validé il me prend qu en h2 et peut-être
un perpétuel en perspective ça
recommence aller très très vite d'autres
approches de tour des quatre menaces
tour des huit d'un match très fébrile
chocques de m'acheter un coude à mach 4
1 des mandats machin qu'il faut faire
échec au roi des deux dames h4
maintenant attaque le pur f2 et oui
comment faire pour gourévitch pour
éviter l'achat maintenant voilà c'est
dingue chèque
et oui oui menace des chèques perpétuer
la série ça nul peut être surprenant
courez vite chez montée en d3 je crois
une file s'est mise il y prend des
risques d'âme des uns oui mesdames d1 le
roi va monter où ça a été très loin le
roi dame dire il a fait gratuit oui mais
où
où le roi montrent bien le roi henri iv
à robert et d'un machin là machin et
leroy montano 5e mais tu vas te faire
mater là et non non ce n'est pas moi
c'est les gourévitch qui va se faire
mater et oui le roi le roi va menacer
oui et oui un vaccin msp3 cours et bien
c'est le roi qui attaquent la machette
en croit des six rallyes va hélas des
personnes physiques de mes cinq dates
ici c'est super chaud qu'est ce qui
s'est passé alors qu'est ce qui s'est
passé il ya les données la dame
il a donné la dame gourévitch gagne donc
cette partie et les pièces d'or celle ci
l'a gagné avec les pièces blanches
depuis la première fois dans ce match
gros avantage puisque maintenant il a
des noirs donc effectivement il a un
énorme avantage
il a donné la dame mais ça m'énerve
perdu une partie extrêmement chaude
extrêmement chaude donc maintenant les
joueurs vont se reposer quelques
instants ces marathons mois ces
marathons sauvages ces marathons pour
les nerfs ça
ça fait presque un match normal alors on
va avoir droit à 4 bits ça fait donc 40
minutes de jeu
donc assez qui vaut un semi rapide
alors que oui là nous avons stéphane
debout d'agde où le public est debout le
public est debout alors que nous avons
robert petit en bas à gauche
et oui tout à fait voilà vous avez donc
un trio de commentateurs une sorte de
brochettes voilà avec et bien voilà à la
provençale on me signale puisqu'il ya un
poivron rouge une aubergine bleu et un
robert tout à fait très bonnes vannes
ont signalé merci merci merci oui là ça
devient curieux alors que stéphane
pronostics pour la prochaine partie bien
courrez vite ch gagnants christophe
gagnant je soutiens une grille choc dans
ce match va être intéressant mais moi je
ne me risquerais pas faire de pronostics
face à la loi c'est bien joli tout
gagnant créés tous gagnants que je suis
et blanc il a été très impressionnant la
dernière fois mais elle a perdu ses deux
parties avec les blancs il a pulvérisé
complètement koreich évidemment puisque
c'est son adversaire et là nous avons
les amusements de françois voilà qui
fait donc des effets de style
c'est difficile de commenter ça donc
qu'est-ce qu'est ce qu'on peut
qu'est ce qu'on peut vous dire mise à
part donc voilà yakou revitch là alors
pour l'emploi des gens quelles seront
les demi finales de demain
le mythe finale de demain à biarritz
kasparov contre le gagnant de ce match
gourévitch cas juke et judit polgar
contre l'ivg est ni bas relief
ouais ça va être dur très intéressant la
facture pour j'ai dit et c'est dommage
puisqu'on aurait bien aimé une finale
kasparov ou le gard oui mais on a dit
que c'était dur pour judith contre adam
c'est pourtant un l'arnaqué donc c'était
plus dur contre adamske contre bari
diane passion puisque adam c'est quand
même un des meilleurs joueurs un des
meilleurs joueurs du monde deux parties
semi-rapides donc effectivement demain
très très beau match en perspective mais
l'on ne connaît pas l'ordre des matches
donc on ne sait pas lequel aura lieu en
premier effectivement c'est un problème
voilà donc la
et que nous avons une liste du matériel
haut de gamme ce qui nous permet donc de
nos amusés comme des fous
voilà c'est très sympathique tout ça une
bulle des petites bulles s'agrandir
alors et qui va finir par effacer courez
vite qui était le seul élément
intéressant et l'image voilà d'ailleurs
pour avis shamballa député dépité alors
que nous restons sur stéphane en
centrafrique et la françois notre
réalisateur a énervé gourévitch il est
parti il ne veut plus jouer d'ailleurs
il le signale à l' arbitre non je ne
joue plus c'est là aussi je travaillais
là c'est quand même si la ressource
mené deux fois au score il réussit
encore à gagner c'est la classe comme un
vrai joker gourévitch vélo which à
gagner un premier à chaque fois oui oui
c'est sans doute tout à fait vrai ah oui
d'accord d'accord
excusez moi je parle à mon casque
d'accord c'est la fatigue ça fatigue
faut dire que il ya beaucoup de travail
ici beaucoup de direct et en plus
effectivement le côtes de provence fait
c'est un défi nous sommes en fin de
soirée et nous gardons l'antenne et les
joueurs ah ça y est ça pourrait vite
celle à stephen bright voilà gourévitch
à l'image gritche ou qu ils se serrent
la main et donc que va-t-il se passer
nouveau coup de théâtre
juuk gagne la partie et oui tout ça pour
qu'on ait des blitz de mort subite mort
subite comme la bière hewitt
effectivement un petit une petite mort
subite pour le fun allez c'est parti on
va se dire la bourse jean françois houle
à s'ajouteraient et c'est reparti en
finlande avant cela françaises
s'ajoutent plus en plus vite c'est
normal et normalement voir l'échiquier
voilà tout voilà la position et oui
c'est celle là même c'est la même c'est
la même partie à il n'obtient pas le
sien qu'il ne prend plus le pion go à
bitche mais qu'est ce qui se passe sans
qu'il y avait trois je ne comprends pas
un calice et 4 contres 3 2 c'est très
curieux david choc fait quelque chose de
très très bizarre cette tour inquiets
ces six gourévitch auxquels ils envoient
les coups sûrs contre une préparation de
greccio qu'apparemment c'est
impressionnant ce que fait gourevitch
dispose pas de cession et ils
développent à développer ces pièces et
puis vers amiens le pion à 4 est en
prise quand même robert et il est pris
très par grille ciocarlia gaffe
oui ça a l'air d'être une gaffe de goadv
itx il avait envie de bien des pressions
au sein voilà tout à fait une ressource
ça a été joué évidemment parmi rigaud a
big four en fou lui qui amène à venir
reprendre le foot c'est la pointe
serveurs en prendre et lennar ont
égalisé on dirait un b3 il a provoqué
courage cavaliers cavaliers des six tout
simplement
ouais mais maintenant je pense que gadio
peut-être envoyer ses 4 ouais ça sera
dans l'idée surtout qu'il a besoin de
gagner ses quatre suivi des 500 voiliers
il faut qu'ils envoient tout peut-être
pions prend ses 5 puis en français 5
ou c4 il faut qu'il trouve quelque chose
alexander mentchouk faut être quatre ou
g5 en tout cas il a une belle position
pour jouer pour le gain puisque ces
pièces sont pas mal breivik n'a pas
encore réfléchi encore c'est pas bon
signe ça il est passé sous les 4 minutes
vous rêvez de chez lui reste quatre
minutes 33 ckt le coup et le coût
attendu et c'est bon c'est bon
ces jeunes y va c'est qu'à l'envoi et
des 5 il envoie deux pions non ce que
rollin vite je peux prendre b3
incroyable incroyable ce que tu as des
foyers devront en tout cas ça me prend
b3 d'un me deux grands spectacles ici il
le prend dans me2 d'un mode pour créer
shook non non il prend 1,6 alors que se
passe-t-il l'intermédiaire de rien
d'après bétonnière bioproduits avaient
tous à bercy ce nom là on n'a pas sur
l'échiquier on le voit en garde sur le
grand écran stéphane c'est à dire que
nous voyons en fait le mouvement des
joueurs et nous déduisons les coups
qu'ils ont fait et la dame ou là mais
qu'est ce qui s'est passé s'est passé
quelque chose de retrouver son rang 18,3
des victoires prend des six noms dont on
prendrait six il ya quatre ans on
apprend et la tour à dos et emprises
salaire un peu oui à tout ce qu'a fait
gris chocolat
peut-être mais il peut encore jouer
dameuse à non le cavaliere est comprise
de ces en l'air la volonté a prises afin
de ranger les dames
ouais nan il ya foucher 5 et chaque
intermédiaire à fouché cinqui g5 celui
d'un me de nantes et tours ces deux fous
j'ai cinq échecs speed tour ces deux
forces et non tour c'est le dirait pas
non il push où il a jeté un sac de la
dir est un peu et or ces deux puisque
sur d'improbables infligé cinq échecs
exactement voilà là il n'a pas l'air
convaincu gretsch là il a eu un petit
moment de relâchement
je crois qu'il a un peu oui mais la
menace cavaliers de la cavale et d2 et
ouvrir par cavalier penser car très
éventuellement oui tout raciste haïkus
revitch un grand défenseur des gens qui
essaient 3 green shoots il se replace il
se remobilise et non ainsi qu'il
remobilise ses forces
on n'y croit pas trop mais bon et
pourquoi on n'y croit pas il ya après
tout un seul pion de plus pour
gourévitch il a toujours le roi au
centre après dur il n'y a aucune raison
que ça ne soit pas bon pour rich ou que
robert je crois oui tout à fait je
n'avais pas compté les pions mais eh oui
ça a l'air impressionnant pour
gourévitch mais n'y a pas de temps du
pion que sa cave et débit si je crois
qu'il agit non c'est impossible dans les
joints d'autres cas les dérivés est un
mec au real il a son plan il veut
échanger les pierres et bien maintenant
prendre cavaliers prend une tourbe et de
est alors donc jusqu'à la tour et
s'attaquer et attaquer attaquer exact il
faut trouver autre chose touché cinq
échecs
ça y est c'est fait le roi de quoi vite
chez party quelque part c'est chris shaw
qui réfléchissent qui veut donc dire que
aulas avoue sajoo vie de ses joues vite
oui oui tout reprend 1 6 1 en tous
points 6 et sur pied on prend
à quatre peut-être peut-être le roi noir
est très très mal faut être quatre
échecs aussi est possible c'est
suivirent d'une découverte du cas validé
cinq pour attaquer le cavalier 17
c'est un net avantage en anglais
tchouvachov pour gorée beach olalalala
fantastique ce que fait de ritchot qu'il
a vraiment un pur style d'attac
c'est un attaquant féroce peut-être
lequel il veut revenir sur la case de
trois fous des six food et 6 défense de
grabuge fou prend caprisa cavaliers des
deux qui avait dit à 3pts être dans
cette position
non non il faut laisser le quart des
saints qui est très bien passé ou dames
c'est un cas les détroits il a joué il a
joué puisque s'attaquent les deux
cavaliers
effectivement carlier en trois tons
gagner en trois sets
je ne sais pas c'est cette affaire
relève des réussites attaquer mais
pourquoi roi c'est cette force et vous
aime pas trop cavalier l'affairé troy
qu'il veut faire une case pour cent
malgré tout cas il a joué un petit coup
de pions mais non je crois qu'il joue et
on court au bercail et des deux je
prends moi il va prendre ces cas tout
simplement oui net avantage gris tchouk
net avantage reach ou qu est le bilan
pendule hélas 3 min agovic et une minute
50 à gré tout cas pas clair ça c'est la
mauvaise nouvelle c'est un orage aime
pas trop la série coupe bien faire
gris chocolat peut-être qu'ils me dis
aux cinq ans gourevitch toujours dans
l'optique d'échangés de pièces non mais
je crois que corovic est très mal dans
cette position sur 88 ch est très mal
mais et on voit une constante dans
toutes les parties ou gris chukka jouer
est bien le roi de youtube toujours en
sécurité et celui qu'on va vite je
toujours dans le vent c'est vraiment des
belles parties d'attac
on se croirait au moyen âge allez c'est
le moment de faire une case pour le roi
n'en mangerai apprendre en c4 la gretsch
aucun oui oui avec sa soeur c'est très
fort net avantage énorme avantage le
pion c5 ne peut plus être défendu
on voit le duo dam tour qui fonctionne
très bien retour aussi beau match ça va
être de la mort subite
on vendra un droit à la mort subite quel
match quel match fontaine j'arrive pas à
parler tellement moi je suis pris par le
l'intensité du match
quelle émotion quelles émotions ici ça y
est gourévitch y commence à réfléchir
réfléchir à fléchir de la suite 20 une
39 la grille tchouk commence à accélérer
la cadence
il avait une défense peut-être
gourevitch puisqu'il a vu l'échangé
autour des 8 pour essayer de rentrer
dans une finale il a donné finale sur
ces cinq finales deux tours c'est sa
meilleure chance et robes et 6 il espère
ne pas être bête mais je vois pas
comment il est pas mal après tout c'est
si je crois qu'il ya un mât de force et
rabaisse est obligée non non il va
descendre mais vite c'est pas mat pour
cc3v vite et maintenant oui un coup un
coup comme g3 wave 3 puisqu'il me rendre
à pouvoir envoyer de la chaussée 3 mais
une telle finale et duels mais tu es
superbe ce café gourevitch superbe on
sur le tiers du mat du couloir et oui
c'est une finale deux tours qui a
dernier
incroyable hernu les lois on peut jouer
et quand même bien de plus pour grey
showcase avec trois enseignants il l'a
fait
il a pris la ramasse les pions à
renoncer à leurs gagnants on s'est
complètement gagnant pour green shoots
maintenant ah oui il va prendre les deux
derniers mois là il faut qu'il joue
viguerie show qu'il y aurait toujours
minutes 10 il reste trois pions il faut
surtout qu'il arrive à donner la tour
sur le pion oui oui il va le faire
il revient ça y est on a vu revenir sur
la première qu'est ce qui se passe
qu'est ce qui se passe les tours et en
os la laura pions contrôler un torrent
rien voilà c'est gagnant gagnant
ça y est c'est fini c'est gagnant il
faut qu'il montre le roi et les trois
pions 3 loyal et là c'est bon c'est
agréable chasse il va regagner
incroyable gain facile pour great choc
nathan hédouin s'est pas fait du tout il
lui reste 30 secondes irish hook 31
contours b4 aux sources de cours à
bitche oulala larnack est en marche
c'est pas vrai avec les six nuls
maintenant ça y est c'est nul voila quel
dommage incroyable fin c'est nul au tour
b4 larnack de gourévitch c'est nul n'en
sait encore ça doit être encore gagné
mais ça devant une énorme technique sa
demande surtout beaucoup de temps
investi notent un investissement de
temps hh 6 non il ya une erreur
il ya évidemment une erreur ce n'est pas
la position l'échiquier une fois plus
planté à se sont arrêtés qu'est ce qui
se passe on ne comprend plus très bien
ces cours à vitupérer fléchi impossible
mauvais si le corps pour faire nul alors
que là il faut agrandir le plan sur les
joueurs pour que nous puissions les voir
en pleine action ça y est qu'est ce qui
se passe et ça c'est complètement nul ça
on aimerait bien assez comme ça
complètement nul c'est surtout
complètement gagnant pour les jo tu
penses il reste 33 secondes à gries
chacun ah oui c'est gagnant c'est
gagnant exact c'est le gagne c'est
gagnant incroyable retournement de
situation ce retournement de situation
va la pousser les pions rêve c'est fini
c'est fini le combat las de gris tshuva
adam gourévitch ne peut plus rien faire
qu'est ce qui se passe là on sent un
manque de technique quand même ou alors
on en panique
une panique générale mais je crois que
là non mais l'échiquier de ligier ne
suivrai les jt il est parti ailleurs la
dette n'importe quoi on est à 10 coups
de la poésie faut absolument qu'on voit
les joueurs complètement gagné ça il
faut voir les joues en grand la voie là
c'est le seul moyen qu'on a de suivre ce
qui est en train de se passer
j'aurais aimé tu vas jouer mais est ce
qui peut faire tomber gris chaud qui lui
reste dix sept secondes 17 secondes
alors je progresse vers le reggae c'est
fini voilà nous avons la position avec
le pont de cé d'un vêtement pour
remettre la position il y à un pont du
sénat c'est connu il faut passer la tour
pour les protégés de roy
il reste 14 secondes à gries chacun
voilà ça y est c'est fait le geste
technique va-t-il réussir à mater dans
les temps ouais on n'a pas trop cool là
dessus ça va très très vite pour mater
et la galerie ci égalisation de grille
sur laquelle match égalisation degré de
chou qu une fois de plus égaux à bitche
qui voit encore dans sa bouteille ils
croient pas ils pourraient vite
ah ça y est il y un tirage au sort on va
regarder ses invités on va regarder avec
d'epitech richard gagné
je pense il faut montrer la scène ya
tirage au sort pour la mort subite qui
aura les blancs dans la première partie
mort subite 6ème match
quel match ils n'ont pour fait une seule
nul donc mort subite va être subite
oh la la alors qu'hier en virage
quoi
voilà après un recadrage
vous avez trois commentateurs en cabinet
l'ania un tirage au sort gourévitch est
en train de choisir la couleur qu'il
aura dans la partie non alors c'est
qu'il nous fasse superbe mise en scène
superbe mise en scène jean renoir de
stephen boyd a choix pour gad chokr et
c'est benoit qui a un peu du mal à
lancer la pièce qu'est ce qui se passe
qu'est ce que je fous que choisir on ne
comprend rien on a du mal à lancer la
pièce non c'est terrible que se
passe-t-il
on ne sait pas qui a le choix great
choqué mords de rien alors qu'on voit
pas ce cadre au lille joue quand même
pour le titre de champion du monde
robert est tout à fait vraiment c'est
curieux alors que stéphane sous la
pression nous a quittés je crois qu'il
faut en savoir plus et c'est possible
sur et qu'elle choque pas partie de la
scène et gourévitch reste avec l'
arbitre c'est bizarre qu'est ce qui se
passe ils ont l'air d'attendre quelque
chose avec richard va s'asseoir devant
ce soir avec igor n'avaient d'abord va
consulter igor nataf son consultant de
luxe pour les beats c'est un bon choix
puisqu'il y auront fait un grand
spécialiste il va peut-être lui demander
quelques conseils pratiques qu'elle veut
concernant les ouvertures
ah oui ils attendent que l'échiquier par
l'échiquier gens se remettent dans la
position initiale initial ça doit être
ça va être technique à faire c'est pas
facile du tout
et donc voilà nous avons ici un très
très beau très une très très belle
création artistique artistique
stephen boyd entre nous françois de grox
puisque c'est son nom
donc ici nous attendons on ne sait pas
qui allait blanc mais en tout cas la
prochaine partie c'est simple cinq
minutes par joueur
le gagnant est qualifié c'est simple en
cas de nul on continue oui tout à fait
c'est baraton ces marathons may cry
chukka les nerfs extrêmement solide
quel match extrêmement solide très beau
style d'attac vous revitch un grand
défenseur
c'est coup pour coup toutes ces parties
un coup ça parce que vous savez faire un
moral véritablement dacic pour
gourévitch il mène trois fois au score
il s'est fait rejoindre à chaque fois et
oui et oui oui oui
donc là par contre gritche ne pourra pas
revenir dans celle là si jamais il perd
et oui là il faut il faut assurer aux
culs nuls en six parties quand même
c'est assez que c'est un très très beau
match un très très beau match entre deux
très beaux joueurs et demain par contre
le gagnant va rencontrer gary kasparov
ça c'est pas facile c'est pas facile
pas facile puisque gary hooper en blanc
est très très fort ces grilles choo qui
va jouer avec les pièces blanches donc
avantageux les juke évidemment puisque
vous invite sur la française n'a pas été
très convaincant pour l'instant oui
c'est fait il s'est fait proprement
laminé plusieurs fois voilà nous avons
nous avons ce soir à faire un match
marathon puisque on ne sait pas quand ça
va se terminer robert nous sommes
peut-être là jusqu'au bout de la nuit
oui peut-être mais on n'ira pas trop je
pense qu'il va y avoir une victoire de
creech ou encore moi j'irais bien
quelques nuls quelques nuls pour le
spectacle je pense oui oui tout à fait
tout ça pour prolonger le suspense c'est
très important
c'est très important mais peut-être que
les gens n'ont pas envie de faire nul
ils veulent que ce match se termine au
plus vite et avait alors que
effectivement garry kasparov doit bien
rigoler en regardant ces partis sur
internet réalisée sûr qu'il va suivre le
match qui suit le match puisque c'est
son adversaire de demain qui est en
train d'arriver
garry kasparov et tranquillement dans sa
chambre d'hôtel en train de regarder la
réalisation de françois et oui beaucoup
de poids sur cette réalisation
d'ailleurs si garino regarde je vais
peut-être tomber les lunettes
à ton avis que kasparov préfère j'écris
chocobo à wisches et bien je ne sais pas
cette fois je pense qu'il préfère jouer
regrette choquant mais je pense aussi
puisque il a pris un ascendant
psychologique sur reach ou qu'il a battu
deux fois l'an dernier tournoi mais il a
fait seulement nul ici il n'a fait
seulement de l'itil ses bras de toucan
semi rapide est un excellent joueur il
fait partie de l'élite mondiale
maintenant c'est sûr alors que stéphane
est de retour dans les cabines comme les
ramonvillois un seul pli un oui c'est
l'art c'est un seul but szavay 6 minutes
pour les blancs et 5 pour les noirs ou
là les plans en 6 minutes et donc en cas
de nul en cas de nul c'est les noirs qui
sont qualifiés c'est le nord qui sont
qualifiés écrit tout cas choisi les
noirs gris de choc a choisi ce pari là
non j'ai choisi les normes et on lui a
donné les blancs c'est une folle boys en
a décidé ainsi
la magie a alors je sais pas tout la
magie du avec la non c'est peut-être
cohabitent choisir mais peut-être que tu
as raison puisque les arbitres ont l'air
de regarder les chéquiers géant et se
poser des questions et je suis si green
shoe qu'elle est noire
oui il peut faire nul peut faire nul
mais on n'a pas vu beaucoup de nous dans
cet endroit c'est sûr
c'est sûr que dans ce match à choisir il
faut évidemment prendre les blancs
remarque que les blancs ont tendance à
perdre donc c'est pas évident en fait
c'est vrai c'est un choix complexes
aussi il a fallu faire en fait c'est
pareil c'est si ça se trouve gourévitch
a gagné le tirage au sort est à dire il
ya tout qui va choisir pour avis de
châssis avec les pièces noires oui
gourévitch aura les noirs c'est comme il
le fit une nul lui suffit amerigo avicii
sur l'échiquier géant on a rentré notre
cinq minutes contre 6 oblin voilà alors
c'est la dernière partie de la soirée
great choc contre gourévitch riccio doit
gagner des obligés de gagner aleksander
grad choc
ça y est c'est parti aux quatre allers
c'est la 5e ss de la journée
sylvain on avance sur le là ça
recommence
ah non nouvelle variante de bois vides
puisqu'ils jouent non non non non
vraiment pas de pas de changement les
joueurs en veulent pour leur argent
c'est sûr alors que là on ressasse les
amènera riante
il avait 13 ans incroyable incroyable
incroyable
c'est reparti pour cette variante jeunes
choc est convaincu qu'il a raison faut
pas oublier qu'il a moins de temps aux
révisions qu'il faut qu'ils jouent plus
vite
oui tout à fait mais faux site voila il
donne plus le pion à 4 go à bitche il
joue faux b5 d'abord il avait doublé nb5
il avait donné de turin quatre cavaliers
black des deux colonnes à vue on a
confiance on voit beach non c'est parti
là c'est sûr
c'est sûr que
gourévitch va sortir toutes ces pièces
écrites ou qu'on voit pas trop de moyens
pour relancer pour empêcher bois beach
aux rockets kebede 2e il a beaucoup
réfléchir et chioukhs et oui oh la la
qu'est ce qui se passe qu'est ce qui se
passe c'est très chaud voit vite chez
change des pièces nul lui suffit
c'est très important pour le déroulement
de cette partie vous prendrez 2 alors
que tu peux gagner peut-être un pur par
avoue ses quatre premiers nul lui
suffisait pendant toutes les autres
parties où il devait gagner
oui il a pas réussi c'est vrai a pas
réussi il a pas réussi quand mais là il
va peut-être y arriver et crèches ou
plus par contre quand il a scoré les
scores full 3d fonction des quatre c'est
logique des rubriques de cette audition
a l'air un beaucoup plus tranquille oui
tout à fait c'est l avantage des bois
beach évidemment les positions
tranquille puisqu'il est beaucoup plus
technique peut qu'être choqué katchou
que sa grande force c'est le jeu d'attac
et là il n'ya pas trop attaques qui se
profile sur gourévitch voit le tour à
d'autres la troupe mal placé pour
l'instant nous restons gourévitch va
jouer il faut 7 et non qu'est-ce qui l'a
trouvé il ya trouvé un coup curieux
fossé que 5,4 gagne un pion et oui n'en
gagnent pas à lorient rennes tours b 1
oui mais on peut prendre le sur ces 3 ou
le pion à 3 après ou améliorer ton
enlevé 7 qui serait dangereux
r oui mais on gagne des pions quand même
un tout ça non mais faut cette fois
cette petite robe va être là il arrivé
il a pris goût à la vie dit il l'a pris
il prend tous gardent toujours de j il
prend clairement tout ce qui bouge
gourévitch tomber un ça y est c'est
reparti pour une partie d'attac
un choix curieux de la part de gorilles
puisque quand même il n'a besoin que
d'une nulle là il s'aventure un peu
ouais me peux pas résister il peut pas
résister c'est dans sa nature des pions
il en a pris toute sa vie et c'est pas
son âge qui va arrêter mais fou prend
1,4 menace là je pense que c'était un
choix un peu douteux clermont mais il
peut encore prendre le pion à thouars
goichi encore un pion à prendre et tant
qu'il ya des pions à prendre mais les
prend pour ça cette menace aussi à la
pendule 5 milliards pour grid chouki et
3 minutes 20 pour gourevitch williams à
l'otan échouent calme au plus vite la
gretsch auquel échoit plus vite
il semblerait que dans cette partie
décisive l'avantagent soit passée aux
mains gré de choc
pourquoi courait vite je ne prends pas
ce pion à trois c'est la question qu'on
se posera en ville trois minutes
seulement un boulevard à il a joué damas
cinq n'en fout 1,6 faut pas six mais
bizarre qu'est ce qu'il a appris le
passé surtout recettes retombées 6
plutôt tombé six tours c'est set il a
joué tour s'est vite propositions des
changes n'ont pas tous et 8,6 il a joué
et on s'est vite parce que se passe-t-il
sur ton reprend il vous prend 1,4 c'est
ce qui va se passer il y aura foule 17 à
la fin et gourévitch incident est il
trouve le temps encore de boire d'avoir
de l'eau gourevitch à noter qu'on sait
pas ce qu'il ya dans le territoire
français 6 aussi ton français 6 s'est
joué c'est vrai par des étudiants un 4
pour 1 4 et la partie data qu'encore non
mais ils vous révèlent chez très très
bien ici il est très mal gourévitch il
est très mal d'options français 54 oh la
la zakat et dames bien il aurait tout
simplement c'est fini c'est fini le jeu
le roi des sacres à 3,17 et obligé mais
regardez cette soupe rang et damas qu'un
échec
oui c'est elle mais maintenant il y aura
d'albert aussi sur wade celle d'algérie
fils zidane b6 niggel ya le talent se
grille juke quatre minutes 2 minutes 30
pour bora beach boys et les massacres
cette partie pour l'instant on se
demande évidemment si vous rêvez déjà
fait le bon choix
artclair eh oui mauvaise idée que de
prendre les noirs oui ou tout simplement
d'aller chercher ses pions à la drogue
elle s'appelle pardon il a trouvé une
défense pourrait amener un damien c'est
fini il n'y a pas moins trois heures il
a joué damas 5e mais d'apprendre cette
tour bien tout simplement d'un premier
set n'apprend a4 est tombé 1 est tombé 1
et sajoo ouais mais ya rien d 8 échecs
d'abord elle tournait un nom mais c'est
ya une qualité plus quand même pour gros
abidjan ya une qualité de plus il a
trouvé une défense me henri gourévitch
en 7e position
je pense qu'au gré tout va quand même
prendre cette tour mais ça ça ne lui
plaît pas d'un premier set concernant
les chances des attaques non mais là
d'un professeur conserver chef d'attaqué
qui peut jouer fou prend tour mais il a
fait faux pro tour c'est plus normal
faut prendre maintenant gourévitch pas
pouvoir au quai ou échanger les dames
sur thur français 5 il va chauffer au
set c'est sûr sur fou oui voilà il va le
faire là il à la pièce dans la main il
faut cette saillie en sachant qu'en
finale il ya des chances deux nuls deux
minutes deux minutes pour gourévitch 4 3
minutes 30 pour le choc qui est des call
shop org est chaud que l'élevage madame
cette île objets bourobine j'avais des
cadres ça fait mal même ses sept îles y
attaquent b si ça fait mal car elles
étaient quatre non il n'a chanté j'ai le
fou et prix suivie d'un v8 échec froid
17 rodez 717 il sort ses pièces
gourévitch il a encore des chances de
nul il a des chances daniel il devient
les deux minutes et 3 minutes 20
agréé tchouk c'est hyper chaud c'est une
place pour les deux demi-finales contre
kasparov dans cette coupe du monde déjà
les prend re prend qu'à jouer mes shoots
pour ses 1 sera normal pour jouer d'un
v6 échec est rentré dans une finale
favorable voilà tout à fait bienvenu
robert qu'est ce qui peut faire
maintenant
il est moins bien et moins bien il est
sous pression doit vite mais il a des
ressources defense en 18 mai d'un proche
est là la donne et le pion tout
simplement d'appoint injuste daschle
après oui il a fait une fois la noce
c'est une partie d'attaqué et ça y est
c'est gagnant au rez-de-chaussée gagnant
il va tout ramasser a le droit il faut
ensuite un tout wen ont même été foutu
bon réveillon
quel talent quel attaquant et oui petite
menace tourbe et vite
et oui et oui et oui le match du couloir
c'est vraiment une au fond ils nous font
une thématique nous font une percée du
grand spectacle vraiment là il va bouger
le pion à la bouche de la tour oui s'il
a oublié tomber 8la gourevitch va
prendre le pion à 3 oui madame g min ça
rentre
les aventures avec damas est debout
rawicz obligé et rien n'est fait là
c'est pas fini ma cette menace france et
et oui la souffrance est simple tout à
fait robert et il n'a pas vu l'ajout h
4g 6 il a joué d'abord gourévitch j'ai
mis plus fin oui puisqu'il faut prendre
ces 5 il y avait peut-être des choses et
oui oui vous prendre c'est ça qui me
semble un clouage tour c'est un oui mais
la dame était en prise stéphane may fois
ci c'est plus c'est moins risqué
c'est sadida ma chute mais là il peut
jouer fou prend ses 5 mai mais à foot
français 5e c'est pas un rythme assez
clair
e leroy noah mais dom vayssette ils
essaient de gagner un peu de temps une
minute 14 seulement pour gourévitch
contre deux minutes vingt deux pour
grichka d'investiture il va falloir
qu'ils accélèrent gourévitch un maintien
la pression autant leurs dames 7 faut
qu'il ait changé d'avis je me sens et le
geste technique le geste technique qui
n'a pas été effectuée tourabi qu'il a
préféré faire alors que claude choquet
la randonnée saddam
ça va casef 4 effectivement c'est je
préfère quand même la position des
blancs il ya beaucoup plus de chances de
magouilles évidemment andelys médaille
peut simplement jouer des coudes
attentes
vous cherchez qu'il ait mis autant et
de toute façon il est mieux sur la
position ils risquent pas perdre il 59
sur l'or devrait être réveillé la
conscience la pourriture monter sa tour
50 50 secondes
il va jouer autant meshoe qu il lui
reste deux minutes quasiment ouhlala oui
criciuma galère et pourquoi catch up a
gagné parce qu'il est beaucoup mieux au
temps et à la positionne v2 propose
l'échangé da et à la position courageuse
il améliore une améliorer violé une
gamine à meylan rien au foot et 4 il
menace qu'elles changent les dames tout
le temps où là c'est ce qui s'est passé
il a réussi à appliquer le pjd a piqué
le pion au 5 mai il a piqué le pion aux
cinq gourévitch et ça y est il appelé
passe maintenant la surmultipliée et ça
y est c'est la même sans pion aux cinq
fantastiques ce que fait gourévitch
c'est le retour c'est le retourner 40
secondes 40 secondes et il lui fait la
thématique technique
est-ce que gorée vite jeu va perdre
autant dans une position gagnante ça
serait terrible ça serait vraiment eric
adams et quatre non ride montrent toutes
ces pièces qu'on va vite ça y est là je
crois que gourévitch a pris l'ascendant
sur youtube dans cette partie il est en
train de revenir en force à être se
prend pour bien il 25 contre 35 secondes
ouh là là là là c'est tout tempo c'est
tout impôt c'est fantastique
il ya tomber si ces chats qui est
d'amener un après on aimerait toujours
on l'a pas vu ça arrive tout cas assez
chic et alain lange qu'est ce que c'est
crispant riche bouquet mieux la dame
bien on a écrit toutes menaces malawi
magazine arrive quelques sur mon avis
trois semaines les 20 secondes ans est
terminée loi il devrait jouer quelque
chose c'est maria dam des cinq atouts
qui menace je ne crois pas que
gourévitch trouvera défense temps mais
cette c'est fini pour des sets 3 6 6 3
et 6 h et serge foucher son chasseur
c'est bien thomas 3 5 qui s'est presque
match normal s'il doit y avoir un
matellois il faut toucher 5 et tourcoing
et sète peut-être qu'il veut je regarde
tous qu'un mois et menace d'un v8 après
ce qu'il a joué il a l'air confiant gré
choc et oui sachant qu'il n'a que 16
secondes me refais gourevitch oui il va
y avoir d'amd 8
ça doit être mat tous indemnes des
wwoofers 4 x 4 3 des cats
non non il en est amélie d'abord roi des
quatre vaste échiquier qui est l'info et
trois ans et crack est vraiment trop
lent voilà impossible à saillé sayed
ahmed 4 notre très mal gourévitch il se
bat il se bat mais lui reste douze
secondes donc on peut dire que c'est
fini
pratique mais il peut échanger les dames
tout simplement oui c'est si c'est
terminé
c'est incroyable voilà gris chaud va se
qualifier
c'est sûr maintenant il se bat quand
même gourévitch il continue fighting
l'assomption des goodrich
il a son pion des oui mais il a pris de
court ses 6000 à 10 secondes
il appelait pioncer 6 à 10 secondes huit
secondes
oh là là là aussi les réfugiés dire que
tu peux être un il y aurait ce 7
secondes seulement à aidant c'est fini
je ne comprends pas ce qui se passe je
ne comprends plus je ne comprends plus
rien à la position il faille que vous
rêviez j'ai un bail qui promet à deux
secondes du reste de scrooge aurait vite
olalala on sent qu'il va tomber dans la
forêt dense et dans la la pendule à tout
arrêter tout cela joue à tempo éprouvant
les joueurs il faut vouloir laisser
ambitionnant voir les joueurs ça va très
très vite
et oui c'était alors que l'arbitraire
tenté d'intervenir ou la corée vite j'ai
regardé gourevitch a perdu ça se voit
eric lèvent les bras au ciel
il a gagné 17 ans et il se qualifie pour
les demi-finales de l'aja du championnat
du monde deux parties rapides
superbe match fantastique dans mais un
match vraiment très très chaud en
intensité stéphane vraiment du grand
spectacle ce soir vous impossible de les
commenter ça c'est ça va trop vite ça va
très vite cours-y vite su nous lie et
des suppléments inédits chez mirego
rawicz on le voir partir donc eh bien
nous allons lâcher l'antenne puisque le
match est terminé donc vous donne rendez
vous demain à 14 heures pour la première
demi finale qui sera probablement
kasparov contre gries tchouk la beau
match en perspective
très beau match on vous donne tous
rendez vous demain à 13h55
tout ça pour un superbe match merci à
tous de nous avoir suivis et à demain
ce